hey everybody no it's not monday again
we're just doing a tuesday extra i
should you know what i should do i
should probably just make a generic
a haunting show because then we don't
have to worry about like yeah we'll do
on mondays but then if we do it on
another day i don't feel like really
weird about it
you know
oh well okay
that's the drink
what oh yeah what did you make
it's rum pineapple juice and just a
little touch of damn passion fruit
yeah it's good yeah
samantha says the house in this episode
has seen way too much paranormal
activity and demonic activity and should
be bulldozed i kind of feel like when we
were watching it last night tom said i'm
pretty sure like they used that same
house like on another episode i couldn't
it did it did look familiar but i don't
know if they used it on another episode
or if
we just seen this episode so many times
i had forgotten about this episode and
i'm glad somebody like recommended it
because i was like this is a really good
one and i had completely forgotten about
it yeah it's like a movie yeah um did
no this
that i'm pretty sure that house was used
in several at different episodes the
front of that house they painted it but
i remember that architecture i think
they painted that house three or four
times i wanna say and i don't know if
this is correct i'd have to go back and
watch it but you know the episode they
did about um
[ __ ] man what was that dude's name like
the
the well from hell thing like with uh
yeah arnie whatever that like end up
killing somebody later yeah i kind of
thought that like they used the house
for that but i could be wrong maybe it
just kind of looked like that i'm not
really sure but the one with the yeah
with the well in the back that like the
yeah i remember the demon came out of or
whatever that was based on that real
case arnie cheyenne johnson that's the
yeah
but i think like they they on the show
they actually didn't uh they didn't talk
about how he killed a dude later on yeah
and tried to
use the demon as a uh defense we did a
show about that
man another night damn drinking
we got a drink tomorrow night too
because tomorrow
we don't have to three nights in a row
but it's always fun i'm just glad i
didn't drink that much at the at the
club i just had like two or three of
those with just little cans like my gas
cans yeah it's gonna be a rough week
it is well yeah but well that's what i
told you i said what else is there to do
everybody's still coming in yeah this
was a good episode though it was kind of
like uh it is you know one of one of the
top tier episodes
yeah this was actually season three this
is from the season three yeah season
three
so we've been doing a lot of season four
ones but yeah
yeah danny rowling said yeah the arne
johnson episode was used uh
they did use this house okay so i'm not
crazy
i thought it looked familiar yeah it
wasn't so much the front of the house
that was familiar it was the way that
the yard was situated like in relation
to the house like when they pulled up in
front of it i don't know why it just
like reminded me of that episode so the
episodes kind of blend together anyway i
have a hard time telling them apart if
you've watched a bunch of them at once
and over time they kind of blend
together so
they do yeah so you know seeing the
house
more than once you you don't know if
it's your imagination or what
oh uh we got to say uh thanks to um
yeah we got like a little shout out to
a friend of the show
louie yeah
who sent us look at that it's a
steelbook edition
book of zakaria that's a great cover
actually i've seen sicario and i thought
i thought he said that to me already but
it wasn't a steel book that i don't have
a steel book of it
so maybe he sent that to me i think he
sent that to me before and i didn't
review it so now he's saying review the
[ __ ] movie we still haven't yeah
because you watched it yeah when you
didn't see it though i don't think yeah
well you and um me and so you and sophie
watched it like one day when i was
working like when she was visiting and i
did so i didn't get to i didn't see it
yet yeah i think i think maybe sophie
gave me one of those that's what i'm
thinking maybe sophie gave us the first
one maybe yeah so maybe because maybe
that's why she second one she's here i
got the second one too yeah you know
what i mean i still haven't seen that if
somebody sends me something like that
i'm gonna be like okay yeah i'll review
it but yeah i guess we never reviewed it
i've just seen it no we haven't reviewed
it because like i said i'm i'm sure i
have it's a great movie
i kept meaning to get around to it but
the second one's even better i just
never did yeah
but yeah so uh yeah we've talked about
that before too about how i think like
the main i really like a haunting it's
kind of like
because all the um you know most of the
titles of them are so generic like you
always kind of like forget which one but
in a way that's kind of good because
then you can watch them over again and
go oh this is this one yeah you know
what i mean so when we first started i
couldn't remember like which one the
presence was because like i said that's
a very generic title so when we started
watching i was like oh yeah yeah yeah
like this one's actually really good
so you know that's how that happens so
you still like a surprise like every
single time maybe that's why they maybe
that's why they named them like that
they're they're extremely rewatchable
anyway they are yeah i mean it's like
junk food tv real relaxing yeah i don't
know what it is i i think it's i mean
it's the guy's voice it's the music yeah
it's a lot of stuff kind of a familiar
cast you see the regular ones come back
and you're like hey they were the ones
that like have the demon pull their face
off in that other episode
can kind of you know stretch stretch
credib uh credulity but that's really
when you start getting into [ __ ]
season seven and eight when season eight
is pretty rough
okay now there are a couple of good now
we've been re-watching season eight we
saw it like during its first run like a
long time ago but we just bought it so
we watched like the first it's only six
episodes yeah so um we watched like the
first three or four and like the first
couple were five okay yeah they i was
like oh these are actually pretty good
and then like i said they get to the
mommy one and i'm like oh that's this is
where we started this is where we
started going off the rails i see and i
think there was a couple of billy bean
ones in that in that in that season
yeah because i think we had encountered
billy bean like once before
but yeah we talked about bill his
ministry yeah
uh
jack marlon says top five best episodes
of a haunting ooh that's hard
um because we can't remember the names
well you're gonna say haunting and
haunting a summer wind i mean that's
probably like the best one uh haunting
the summer wind i think is the best one
um the pilot episode that had mr mr
gordy that's a haunting injury in
georgia that's pretty good
um
haunting in connecticut that was the one
that was another point where the boy was
thought he was dying and and yeah
thought he was dying and we were seeing
the funeral home the funeral home yeah
right yeah yeah that was that one yeah
we don't have that one either that's
that's one of the pilots you have to buy
that one i think
i think the two pilots might come in a
different dvd or they're separate
because i think because they're pilots i
think they're like longer i thought they
were like movie length
i know that we did
i'm pretty sure we did we talked about
both those i know we did haunting in
georgia the apartment was good monster
in the apartment
yeah we should probably do that one one
of these because devil's child that one
was really oh yeah demon child demon
child yeah uh oh and then uh
the one with the uh when they were in
taiwan
the ghost it was hungry ghosts hungry
ghosts yeah good one somebody brought
that one up yesterday yeah hungry ghost
um
trying to think what else yeah those are
pretty much the ones i probably would
have picked as well
yeah those are the top ones i think
those are like the ones that stood out
the most because they had something you
know like hungry ghosts had something
like different about it because it was
set in thailand and there was a whole
different like vibe going on taiwan
taiwan sorry thailand
two completely different countries
bobby mackey's was okay
yeah i was gonna say that i didn't mind
the bobby mackey's one yeah and like the
yeah ones that are kind of set in bars
and stuff like that those kind of see me
well but there's another one there's
another one that maybe we should look
into doing which was the wheat chief
horror squishy that i think was like set
at a british pub or irish club i can't
remember where that one was i remember
running in ireland yeah i remember that
one being okay yeah
um
the haunted victorian
i remember that one sally's house was
pretty good yes we did a show we did a
show about that one too
with all the toys in my house moving
around was that sally's house no
which one
i mean i know which one you're talking
about but i can't remember like which i
don't remember the name of that one zach
said have you guys ever done a full on
show about bobby mackeys yes we did yeah
it was a while back there's one you guys
can remember it we'll review it i just
don't remember the name of it jack said
it might be the calling might be the
calling i'd have to check some people
move into a house and this house was
given to
a freed slave back in the 1800s for his
like service rendered i think and he
lived in it and died and then later on
some white people moved in there i hate
him like that yeah and he was on that
house and it said they'd wake up and
he'd they'd see this like [ __ ] scary
old [ __ ] black dude with white eyes
in the [ __ ] 1800s clothing with his
damn cowboy head going this is my house
this is my house and [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah this is your house and just the
dude they got to play the ghost and
everything it was [ __ ] spooky looking
it looked kind of like a
uh [ __ ] like a black clint eastwood
coming after your ass didn't he kind of
had that kind of he did it it's been a
while but yeah we'll see if it's it
might be the calling i can't remember
with the name i remember what you're
talking about but i can't read any of it
because like i said they always just
they just have like generic titles he
went that hat and the way he was dressed
just reminded me of my high plains
drifter which is another ghost story a
revenant story yeah a lot of people
don't realize that clintus will be high
plains drifters paranormal
[ __ ] paranormal normal paranormal
[ __ ] story is basically the crow
it's basically the same story as the
crow just people don't realize it that's
a ghost
danny danny rowling said a canadian
ghost would say this is my hoos
[Laughter]
there was a canadian series that had
some really good [ __ ] remember they had
the uh that's right i forgot all about
that the korean canadian guy who was the
uh yeah that's right what the [ __ ] was
that show called each each episode had
three or four stories in it they were
all very short yeah which led lended
credibility to me because the stories
weren't very complicated just people
would go to a house and they'd
see something and they never could
figure out what it was it wasn't a long
drawn out yeah i remember liking that it
was yeah and it was shot in canada in an
abandoned skyscraper
yeah that's right down somewhere in
ontario or something and it was real
good uh i don't remember the name of it
though
i don't either but it was good yeah
yeah jack said i think the first four
seasons are better than the new ones
yeah they are
i mean we've done a lot of episodes from
it but we mostly stick we own the first
because i don't know like if you've
watched a lot of these that we do but we
own the first
seven seasons and we just bought the
eighth season
like online
and we've been rewatching that and a
couple of those are good but yeah after
about season five or six they started to
go kind of like not so good then you
guys can remember what that canadian
series was i'll try to buy it because i
want to see it again
yeah mysteries of the unexplained no it
wasn't this is fine it was
just stories i don't remember what it
was um
we just randomly came across it on i
don't know if it was on destination
america or discovery or something like
that like when we were flipping when we
stepped cable we were flipping through
there
yeah danny rowling said too bad the
first two episodes didn't come with the
first four seasons i know i guess they
figured they could just sell them
separate because they were movie length
i should buy it because i don't have
them you know but i'm pretty sure you
can get them on dvd though are they both
on one dvd
uh i i don't know
you'd have to like uh
look into that
what's she doing
this is ridiculous
she's this is ridiculous she's laying on
her back and she's totally flattened out
and she's like she's sleeping you have
like a badger we're flattening out and
going underneath the door she looks like
she's been flattened out look at
something look like you've been run over
pokey don't say that i know that he just
looked flat as a board she's
she was playing with her little mint toy
over there and i guess it tuckered her
out she's been hilarious all day just
pestering us
honestly
trying to get us to do something
she just yeah she just constantly wants
attention i think we were talking about
that yesterday how it's just like having
a kid because they're like mom
mom mom
mom hey oracle do you remember the name
of that um paranormal series it was
canadian
and they had a canadian korean guy who
was like the the host
and uh he i think he's korean i mean you
know i lived in korea he looks like a
korean
uh but you know from canada and and he
was always introduced in the next case
he was up like on an event on a floor of
an abandoned skyscraper from like the
20s or the 30s overlooking a canadian
city might have been ontario there's a
really good series each episode had i
don't know about four or five little
bitty like 10 minute
ghost stories this is something that
somebody saw or a poltergeist story or
something that was kind of i don't
remember it though i don't remember the
name of the it had good music it was
around the same time as the haunting
zack says haunted canada or yankee
vampire said was it paranormal
encounters paranormal encounters it
might have i think that is i think
that's what it was jackson normal
jackson what do you think about the
paranormal activity movies um the first
one i i kind of liked the first one but
i haven't really i didn't like it enough
to
watch any of the other ones but i did
like the first one i have it actually i
own it but
the other ones i was just kind of like
man i think i've seen enough of that i'm
not a big found footage girl you know
some of them are good found footage
movies i tend to prefer ones that are
like mockumentaries more than like
straight up found footage but there are
like you know there are some found
footage ones that i like but so it's not
usually like a genre that i seek out all
that much or that i'm all that into but
you know i have liked several of them
uh hey are you guys canadian i don't
know i'm new to your channel no we're in
florida yeah uh actually we're
southerners well i'm a southerner you're
you're originally from california but my
family's but you're saying your family
yeah and i grew up in mississippi about
half one third of the time yeah yeah
yeah we're we're in
central florida pretty much not too far
from orlando matter of fact
oracle says uh oh is pookie doing a flat
flat cat plank is she still doing it
yeah she's awake now though
she's like she's laying flat on her back
and her little back feet are sticking
out like that and then like her then her
paws her front paws are like that and
she's just like
looking off into the distance she crazy
she just lays like that all the time in
the middle of the floor she's she's a
nut all right so are we ready to start
talking about this episode yeah go ahead
or
no i'm gonna check on some stuff you're
gonna check out some stuff yeah i wanna
see if that was called paranormal
encounters i think
yeah i think that sounds right
but like i said there's so many
paranormal shows and they all have names
like that like i said it's canadian
paranormal documentary
premiered in 2005. so yeah that's it
okay 81 episodes four seasons of it
um god damn i know we didn't see [ __ ]
yeah
i can
yeah lawrence ciao that's it lawrence
ciao yeah so thank you thank you chinese
he's he's chinese ethnic background not
korean but that's a chinese name
but i thought he looked korean to me
he's a real good host all right yeah i
liked him i liked him as a host he was
very charismatic yeah he's a young guy
he's in a suit he's up there and he kind
of like almost kind of reminded me of
rod stewart where's your rod stewart rod
sterling
sterling yeah yeah yeah
is this earlier
yeah it kind of reminded me of him you
know with with the uh
uh uh introducing the twilight zone
episodes he's kind of like that
yeah kind of yeah i like the host not as
not as not as spooky but he's a little
more light-hearted but his
light-heartedness [ __ ] made him kind
of spooky do you notice that
yeah i get what you're saying some of
the paranormal stuff kind of had a
hopeful message you know like near-death
experiences when people loved ones
coming back from the grave to give a
message you know what i mean so he kind
of some of it was kind of uplifting it's
a good it's a real good
series only four episodes or four
seasons
81 episodes i wonder if you could buy it
i scream it yeah i imagine you can
probably stream it yeah you can probably
stream it for free honestly probably but
yeah thanks for telling us because i
would never have because like i said
it's just kind of like look we found um
that uh that show from 2019
with william shatner on it
uh that's just called the unexplained
it's good like with an x and it's really
good but i'm just like can you guys like
think of better names for shows so
they're not all yeah
so they don't someone get them all
confused it's like happening with like
some punch or something like that you
know what i mean uh danny rowling said
the mom's
logic of sticking a picture of jesus in
the closet was very smart nobody
nobody ever as if that would drive away
a demon yeah uh yeah we'll get into the
picture jack when you look at it when he
says i always thought that the ghosts
and summer were native americans i
didn't believe in the carver angle if
you actually go back and really look
closely at the summer wind case
that you know the the
photographs the summer wind and stuff a
lot of the
a lot of that tale is easily explained
by the photographs of what [ __ ]
somerville suburban actually looked like
it was in bad condition all right there
was nothing there
um i don't believe there were any ghosts
i don't know
maybe there were but
a lot of the stuff in that story that
makes that story so interesting can be
easily explained by other things
you know they didn't want to come work
on the house because the house was
[ __ ] falling apart
didn't matter how much money you'd
[ __ ]
sink into that house it was never going
to be anything based on the photographs
that wood was [ __ ] ready to go that
house looked like it was getting ready
to fall down
so
bad investment if you ask me
and it burned down but somebody burned
that down because that thing was an
eyesore and it was in between two other
pretty nice houses
you know out in the country off of a
lake
you know kind of a resort area and i met
teenagers were going in their party and
so i imagine those neighbors like sick
of that [ __ ] they went in there with
some diesel fuel and set that [ __ ] on
fire well it was probably bringing down
their property bringing down about
property value and everything it was
just it was
that house was a waste man
based on the photographs
the architecture was shitty and what it
was made out of looked like [ __ ] it was
just looked like damn near untreated
wood it wasn't built to last when you
looked at it
zach says i just googled lauren's chow
and who boy i forgot how fine he was he
was like he was pretty foxy i remember
he was a good looking guy he was yeah
right still is good looking i mean
he's not dead or anything i don't think
just like yeah i'm sure he's still a
good looking guy that wasn't that long
ago yeah he's probably 50 now yeah
that's that's all right that's not old
all right danny rowling said uh someone
should try and locate the house used in
this and many other episodes this one i
think will probably be harder i couldn't
really find because this is one of the
ones where they didn't use their real
names and they wanted to be in shadow
so
you couldn't really find and honestly
they were they were pretty vague about
where
i don't even think they ever said what
town it was in
which i'll get into in a minute uh so
yeah are we ready to talk about it yep
all right
so the main uh woman that's talking uh
this is not her real name but on the
show they called her sarah miller and
again not her real name so she just
appears in
silhouette as does her daughter so
apparently she has a son and she had a
husband and stuff like that but they
didn't appear on the show so you only
have the mom and the daughter and then
later on you have the paranormal
investigators who show up like you know
their real selves
but they didn't want their uh their
identities known now the location given
is only northern california which yeah
that narrows it down uh just basically
says in the shadow of the cascade
mountains it said that now it is stated
later in the program that they had moved
from reading california which i think is
in sacramento county yeah
um
but i'm not sure if that's true or not
if they're just trying to like throw you
off the trail
so i don't know but maybe they really
didn't want anybody knowing who they
were
so starts out it's fall of 2000. so
sarah is a single mom and at the time
she has a 13 year old daughter that
we're calling becky
and a five-year-old son that we're
calling jack
so she has just bought like this small
kind of three-bedroom ranch house she
said she'd saved up for a few years uh
you know to buy it so that she'd have
like a better place to live i guess
they'd been living in an apartment in
redding california i presume i don't
know if they were just like trying to
throw people off the trail or whatever
so uh so becky the teenager is being a
real [ __ ] teenager about this whole
moving situation you can't really blame
her i mean she's 13 you know she's uh
pissed off because she had to move 90
minutes away from her old hometown and
all of her friends so if they actually
did move from reading it's somewhere in
northern california 90 minutes away from
reading so i don't know where that is
um but yeah she said i was you know i
had grown up in the city i was used to
the city and this place felt like a
different world so i guess they moved
kind of out in the middle of nowhere a
little bit
so they move into the house uh the
furniture isn't going to show up until
the following day so the family all kind
of camps out and the living room floor
in front of the fireplace because i
guess it's cold
so there's a storm and the power goes
out
and then becky has to she's like well
how am i supposed to go to the bathroom
now like she's very like i said she's a
very
teen about everything how am i supposed
to go to the bathroom now so her little
brother is like uh well i have a
flashlight like what you're writing so
she goes down uh to the bathroom like
and she's weirded out and she said that
even when they first moved into that
house she was like the hallway like
always really scared her for some reason
she didn't really like to walk down the
hallway
so now on the show and this is again
we're going back to the whole thing
where it's like a lot of times they'll
show stuff on the show but that's not
what the person said or they didn't say
that or that that we know of
so on the show she's in the bathroom and
she's washing her hands or whatever and
there's like a creepy face behind her in
the mirror that shows up during a
lightning flash like it's lightning and
then there's a face back there like over
her shoulder
but she didn't actually say that she saw
that and actually i will say to the
show's credit that they didn't actually
show her seeing that either it was just
kind of like she was looking down at the
sink and then poo poo you know what i
mean like the lightning flashes there's
shadowing there's a scary face back
there
um i guess they were just trying to
convey that she was like creeped out or
she felt like she was being watched or
something like that they do that a lot
on the show if somebody says i felt like
i was being watched then they feel
justified to like shows put some [ __ ] in
the background that like they don't see
they're trying to make a good episode
sure so i can understand it and it does
does interest you enough in the case to
where you try to research it yourself
right if you're interested like i said
this one you couldn't really because
they didn't give their real names and i
didn't even really like know how to
narrow it down so much so you just gotta
go and i don't necessarily think that
that's that that's
means that the people were lying a lot
of times that
that adds a little bit more to it
because
we were gonna they were we were going to
go on a haunting and lois and red were
afraid to appear on the haunting they
didn't want their relatives to [ __ ]
think that they were crazy
but the relatives knew
so i don't really but they didn't
believe it they weren't there
and the thing about it is that
i don't know it's like when they were
talking to us about it and you were like
well
you know you can be on the show like in
silhouette or whatever but then the
thing about it is that if you're on
there like with your face
and you know and you say oh my aunt
uncle then obviously like through
deduction like everybody can figure out
who that well i got nine ants on my
mother's side so it could be so it could
be that's true it could be yeah but what
the deal is is that the ants all [ __ ]
didn't believe they were all real
hardcore christians and they didn't
believe in that [ __ ] right because their
dad was a baptist minister
and they thought he was full of [ __ ]
okay so therefore ideas like demons and
devils and [ __ ] like that that's all
[ __ ] too a lot of times the [ __ ]
the children of ministers and clergy are
the [ __ ] biggest disbelievers because
they're like oh dad was full of [ __ ]
yeah well they grow up with that they
grew up with that yeah like you know
they probably see a lot of the
hypocrisy and stuff like that like first
hand
my granddad was [ __ ] weird he was a
[ __ ] aerospace engineer
worked for [ __ ]
nasa grumman
[ __ ] uh
grumman aerospace mcdonald douglas was
on some [ __ ] badass projects but they
recruited a lot of those guys from
religious schools because they could
trust them
you know and they're right
but he was also [ __ ] ran a little
ministry and [ __ ] out of his house
you know [ __ ] had a fellowship would
come over like 12 people they wouldn't
have television no television you could
have a radio but you couldn't have
television
it was like see i mean that's like some
hardcore [ __ ] yeah right i never knew i
never knew anybody i knew some like
pretty religious people growing up but
nobody i didn't know anybody that was
that every one of my aunts was out of
there moved out of that house by the
time they were 14 or 15. they wanted the
[ __ ] out of there and it was like
it was like a full family anyway you
know they had a ton of kids
yeah they were trying to be root full of
multiply and only had one uncle on that
side
and um yeah as soon as they were 14 or
15 they were [ __ ] split bye yeah lois
and my mom split together well like i
said i always i don't blame you if i'd
grown up like that thankfully too strict
my parents were not strict too strict
and were not religious my mom was like
14 and lois was like 16 and they [ __ ]
said or 17. lois was old enough to
[ __ ] get an apartment [ __ ] and she's
like i'm out of here you know what come
with me and you're like yeah let's get
out of here
you [ __ ] laughed yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
i mean they're the kind of thing where
they're [ __ ] oh we got a present
everybody guess what we got today we got
candy we got one snicker bar here we're
gonna cut it up [ __ ] it and then give
people little pieces of a snicker bar
okay then next week we'll eat the other
sticker bar you know they got money
i can't i can't with people like just
kind of like
like look if people want to be like that
that's on you fine i'm not you know i'm
not saying people shouldn't be allowed
to be like that i'm just saying that
i don't want to hang out with you
and it's like it kind of sucks for the
kids because they didn't really have a
choice did they yeah right they're like
what the [ __ ] is it right
it's like you know you're imposing that
[ __ ] on your kid your kid's like yeah i
don't like this really i don't know yeah
i just want to [ __ ] shouldn't have
brought a candy bar at all is that one
candy bar and cut it off that's what i
mean it's almost like worse than having
no kids
you know what i mean i just get six
candy bars give each one on a candy bar
yeah they're going to give them all the
one little piece of candy every day
we got six candy bars everybody's gonna
get a little piece every day of this
candy bar well what because they don't
well they don't want them to indulge or
they don't want them to get fat or
whatever probably just like indulgence
and patience and [ __ ] and being you
know what i mean and cooperating you
know they they read into like well i
mean i get that and those are like noble
things to teach your children i'm not
saying that but i'm not really sure
that's the best way to go about it
i don't know i'm that's i only have i
only have cats are christians man you
have i only have cat children
you have christmas that's one day where
you open up all the goddamn presents
it's not hanukkah where you [ __ ] open
up one present one present every day
every eight days like that yeah yeah
we're doing christians now here you know
but yeah they tried to get all hanukkah
on them
i was trying to explain that to [ __ ]
jewish guys
yeah yeah
i was trying to explain that [ __ ] to
[ __ ] rob levinson the [ __ ] friend
of the show who said some [ __ ] he's
jewish and i was seeing it and said you
don't understand about and [ __ ] because
there's a big streak of old testament
stuff in there well yeah they do a lot
and when you piss they'll use [ __ ]
terminology from the old testament
they'll say shalom and [ __ ] like that
and the matter they get the more old
testament they become which next thing
you know they have the right to [ __ ]
kill you
you know and so
they start [ __ ] quoting [ __ ] moses
and [ __ ]
you gotta watch you gotta watch you
gotta watch with those people you gotta
watch it yeah just saying we're gonna
strike you down we're gonna give you
back to god i mean you know i'm sure
most of them are fine but
they could go like you
got to watch it yeah yeah well yeah it's
like the same mindset
it's the same mindset so you got to
watch it
um yeah oracle said as a preacher's kid
yeah we get the backstage view exactly
exactly right danny rowling said in my
teens i knew someone's sister's
boyfriend who was possessed and had
exorcism done scared me to the point
that i started carrying a mini bible
around one summer but grew out of that
real quick
uh all right so where was i yeah yeah
yeah just telling good stories we're
just telling good stories derailing the
show well you know what else is
[Laughter]
that's why we got a lot of people on the
show that's yeah maybe
although like i said well this is better
than a sidetrack show if you ask me
though talking about [ __ ] haunting
it's more fun to me i think although
sidetracks are fun too yeah
and then i don't really worry too much
about it anything where i feel like
there's
where people are coming there to like
mostly listen to a topic yeah
and then we get sidetracked i don't mind
a little bit of sidetracks because you
know it's like i'm kind of like that too
but it's like if we get so much if off
into it we're talking like for half an
hour about something
then i start getting like stressed out
because i'm like going for an hour and a
half anyway because i got a [ __ ]
curry waiting downstairs i made earlier
today that shit's sitting there just
[ __ ]
curing and it's sitting there calling us
yeah it's good it's real good it is we
had some like several hours ago
yeah with chicken and chicken and
potatoes
with stuff that came out of the garden
uh jack marlin says this dave considine
who's the guy that's uh the paranormal
investigator dude
that uh is he the real deal i don't know
i just kind of these types of dudes
i don't think he was rel well
did he have anything to do with the
warrens i don't think so most apparently
i'm investing he had to do with bishop
mckenna which we'll get into in a little
bit and bishop mckenna was one of the
dudes on the smirl haunting
which is kind of like a famous haunting
they made that like movie that tv movie
the haunted about it remember we've
talked about that mckenna was on some
pretty big cases some of them probably
real but i wasn't there i'm right
oracle said we also come here to admire
pookie in beijing when they appear
beijing's never appearing on camera you
know what though yeah but she has been
coming up here to steal food to steal
food from pookie because she has a bowl
downstairs now pookie also has a bowl
downstairs but pokey also has a bowl
upstairs pookie mostly eats from the
bowl right here in my office other day i
looked over there because pookie was
like what was that what was that and i
looked over and beijing was eating off
her dish yeah and then i thought to
myself pookie must have gone downstairs
and eaten out of beijing
it's dishwasher and then beijing was
like [ __ ] you little baby i'm coming up
here and eating off of your dish yeah
you're finally instead of space
that's probably what it was because
beijing hardly ever like comes upstairs
like she comes upstairs sometimes but
it's like she doesn't hardly ever come
in my office and like eat so i said oh
pookie must have eaten off her dish and
she's taking revenge but yeah so uh all
right
so face in the mirror blah blah blah
we're not sure like if that really
happened or not so the next day sarah's
boyfriend steve again not his real name
uh shows up with the furniture now
sarah's mom ruth she comes there too
she's apparently going to she wants to
be closer to them because like i said
where they moved to was like 90 minutes
away or something so she's like well i'm
gonna buy a place like close by
um but until that happens she's gonna
stay in the house so she can look after
the five-year-old right
so that afternoon sarah and becky the
mom and the daughter are in becky's room
like unpacking and becky starts bitching
because like she [ __ ] like pretty
much a lot but it's like i said she's a
13 year old girl that's kind of what
they do so she's kind of like bitching
that it's like freezing cold in the room
now in her interview real sarah says
that rim was very very cold all the time
like significantly colder than the rest
of the house so like as soon as you went
out the door like the it felt totally
fine but that room was like super super
cold
um
and then the actress that was playing
her says oh and it smells funny in here
too now the real woman didn't say that
and they never really bring that up
again so i'm not really sure like why
that was added but whatever
now so they assume that it's just this
vent that's kind of like because the
window has like this big window so it's
almost like a window seat but then it
has like this big vent on it so they're
like oh well maybe it's broken or
something like that i'll have my
boyfriend look at it yada yada now in
her interview real becky who's the
daughter said her mom told her oh maybe
the room is cold because you're at the
far end of the house and you're not
getting the heat or whatever but becky
said it felt like something else like it
didn't feel right so there's that
so steve the boyfriend has to go back to
reading to work the next day i think he
worked on his dad's ranch or some [ __ ]
so he went back there but he's dropped
off all their stuff like he was the one
that drove the truck and brought all
their furniture
so it seems like nothing happened for
like a month like a month goes by they
said
now becky gets woken up one night by
what sounds like voices outside of her
window
real becky said it sounded like a man
and two women
and she said that it sounded like they
were trying to get her attention like i
don't know if they were like calling her
name or something like that but she said
they were talking loud enough like right
outside the window it sounded like that
so it sounded like they were talking
trying to get her attention
so she goes and looks and calls out the
window but obviously there's nobody
there and nobody answers
so the next morning uh becky shuffles
into the kitchen like where the kids and
everybody are like eating breakfast and
whatnot and she's still got her little
jammie pants and she looks all like
you know like that and her mom's like
what the [ __ ] it's like seven o'clock
it's time to go to school or whatever
and she's like yeah there was like all
these voices like talking outside my
room last i got she was like that um but
mom was like oh well it must be just the
neighbors
and then becky's like mom the neighbors
like live super far away like it
obviously couldn't be the neighbors
yadda yadda and uh so then sarah's like
well you're just stressed out and then
like real sarah says oh well you know we
just moved and she doesn't have any
friends she's starting a new school and
blah blah so it's like she's probably
just you know it's probably just anxiety
and she's like you know she's having
some problems or whatever
so a few more weeks go by so i'm
guessing like just from the way they
laid this out it seemed like it wasn't
like a constant barrage of supernatural
activity but it was just like something
weird like every now and then either
that or it was stuff that wasn't like
worth mentioning i guess
so as the next weeks go by
becky said she started to feel a lot
more isolated she's experiencing stuff
like weird feelings and hearing voices
and stuff but nobody else is and nobody
believes her when she says stuff about
it so her and her mom are like not
getting along and she also is not having
that good of a time in school because
she's new and like nobody will hang out
with her and blah blah
now one afternoon grandma takes jack the
little kid to the skate park and becky
stays home to do homework now i think
the mom is home too
but so becky's in her room now she has
this ceramic ballerina music box type
thing
um and it's on top of her tv now while
she's sitting on the bed like reading
her uh you know homework or whatever and
the
apparently the ballerina like slides
over a couple inches like by itself like
on top of the tv and i guess they see
that yeah well i get yeah she said she
saw that yeah so she said it slid over
like it and like that and she was like
what the [ __ ] and like gets up and like
she kind of slides it back into place
like into the center
and then at that point it like
slides off by itself like really fast
and like falls off on the floor and
breaks
so
obviously she freaks out she rushes in
to tell her mom
mom is on the phone and doesn't have
time for her teenage nonsense
uh and she says it was probably just the
vibration from the tv she's like mom the
tv wasn't even on you know she was like
that kind of tone you know what i mean
you guys know
uh so mom thinks becky is just being
dramatic
and she's like look if you hate your
room so much like when grandma moves out
you can have the other room right so
she's like okay fine whatever and then
she like storms back but when she goes
back to her room though
it's totally trashed like there's just
[ __ ] everywhere like there's crap all
over the floor and there's like all the
pictures are crooked or falling off the
walls or whatever and apparently she'd
only been gone for like a minute or
something like when she went in there to
tell her mom about the ballerina and
something is like trashed her room in
the interim
so she's like freaking out about that
she said it looked like quote-unquote a
tornado hit it
so she screams for her mom uh her mom
comes she's like jesus christ i'm on the
phone and then she looks in there she's
like what did you do and she's like i
didn't do it and then she's like
whatever just clean it up you know what
i mean like she was just mad and told
her to clean it up she doesn't believe
her right
so
several months after they move into the
house grandma gets her own place like we
said that's gonna happen she moves out
so becky moves into her room she said it
was kind of a lot better after that
because
uh she said that she felt a lot safer
like in grandma's room and she really
didn't like the room that she had been
sleeping in
so jack the little kid who's five moves
into becky's old room now prior to this
he'd been sleeping in his mom's room
because like i said he's only five
so once jack is in
the cursed haunted room
i guess
jack gets woken up by noises coming from
like inside his closet
so
it just kind of sounded like and like i
said i don't know if this is what
because the he wasn't on the show um but
it sounded like something kind of like
hit in the back of the door or somebody
like stepping around in there or
something like that
so he gets up and like opens up he's a
brave little kid so he gets up and like
opens the door like what the [ __ ] is
going on there like looks in there but
he doesn't see anything so then he
closes it back and then he gets back in
bed like looking very suspiciously like
at the closet door like what the [ __ ] is
going on in there
so then kind of pulling um
they they kind of pulled a poltergeist
on us i feel like
uh because he goes like that like to
look underneath the bed
and then when he comes back up
um
the closet door like opens by itself
and then jack turns around and sees like
two
apparitions essentially like standing
there by the bed he said it's two guys
it's two guys what they show on the
series is it looks like two damn
ku klux k black shadowed ku klux klan
dudes glowing eyes either that or damn
jawas
that would be pretty freaky if you woke
up in those two there's like two jobs
two job was in the clan
because they planned didn't they have
the point wasn't it
i couldn't tell i thought it was just
messy hair but maybe i just saw it like
real quick so i wasn't really sure and
then the mom runs in and he goes i saw
two guys over there he said two guys two
guys yeah
and saying about seeing two [ __ ] jaw
wasn't too clean
yeah i don't think a five-year-old would
know what two clan members look like i
mean i would hope not uh not in 2000.
you showed them like in weird hoods just
silhouettes with red eyes and they're
just both standing there like hey what's
up well that's not what the kids said
well the kid's not on the show yeah the
kid just said two guys the actor kids
said i saw two guys that's what he said
so they may have been taking some
liberties yeah they might have been two
just human-looking people standing there
you know
which yeah again that would be i'm not
sure what would be scary well it'd
probably be scarier to see like people
rather than jawas because java's are
actually kind of cute
so uh so he tells us so his mom and his
sisters then he freaks out obviously so
the mom and the sister like run into the
room and he's like i saw two guys they
came out of the closet but then they
were standing right there like by the
bed and then becky is basically like i
told you there was something going on in
this room mom god damn yeah she's very
gets out about it yeah back he's [ __ ]
up yet well i'm just i know i keep doing
like the teenage voice because that's
what the actors kept doing um
so of course like sarah goes and looks
in the closet but because when you're a
little kid and there's monsters in your
closet
when your parents look the monster is
never there and i'm like well that
doesn't make them go away though either
no i mean the monster goes into another
dimension that's they made a whole movie
about that monsters inc
they go into another dimension
uh so the parents can't see them it's a
whole thing
so so yeah so there's nothing in there
when she checks but jack is like
insistent that he saw them
and becky is like uh you know the kid
can sleep in my room because it's i know
it's scary in here because this used to
be my room and it's like freaked me out
too
now later that same night sarah starts
to maybe think maybe there is something
to like all of this stuff that her kids
have been saying like i don't know
she was like she kind of started to get
scared too because i guess she's like
now they put jack in this room where
uh becky had kept complaining about
weird [ __ ] happening in there and now
jack's complaining about it and she's
like so she doesn't really know if jack
was like influenced by stuff that becky
was saying about the weird [ __ ] in the
room or if there was really something
going on in there
so she's like wondering about that now
she settles into her own room
and as soon as she kind of gets in bed
and lays down she starts hearing
creaking
in her room like and it sounds like
somebody is walking around
inside the closet so she starts getting
freaked out too
and then the phone on her nightstand
rings
and when she picks it up and i'm like
it's the middle of the night i guess i
don't know what time it was exactly
but uh so she picks it up and there's
like a weird it wasn't a voice exactly
i'm not really sure what they were
trying to do but it was like a weird
click like staticky kind of like ooh
spooky kind of thing now i don't know if
that really happened or not because the
real uh sarah did not mention anything
about her phone ringing in the middle of
the night and it being like a phone call
from a ghost or anything so
it's funny because we were watching the
episode i had forgotten about that and
like the phone rings and i said oh it's
the demon calling and then like i was
making a joke and then she picks it up
and i was like oh it is the demon
calling i was just being funny but it
actually was but yeah so the demon
called it um yeah but i don't know if
that really happened or if they just
added that to be scary
so uh so then she hangs the phone up and
then she hears more creaking
from the closet and then becky calls
down the hall it's like are you hearing
that so i guess she could hear it from
down the hall
um so sarah's like okay you guys stay in
your room and she thinks that there's a
person in the house she said i thought
there was a man like an intruder so uh
as in most of these episodes uh the
woman always has a baseball bat like
right next to their bed
uh so she gets her trusty baseball bat
her louisville slugger and goes around
the house thinking that there is an
actual guy like an intruder
now in the living room
uh she's this is very amityville horror
you guys in the living room she starts
seeing blood
start dripping down the wall like it
just kind of comes out of one thing and
then it's like a whole bunch of it comes
down it's an iconic scene it's an
effective scene i remembered this from
the first day that i saw it and it
wigged me out when i first saw it back
in the 2000s
i was like man that that freaked me out
too
having been through a poltergeist
experience as a kid i could imagine
something like this happening and the
bad house that i was in late in later on
i was like yeah i wouldn't like to see
that i could imagine something like that
would happen though or could happen but
that particular effect has never
happened to me
but i could imagine it happening that'd
be pretty freaky if you saw blood coming
out of the wall yeah and it was kind of
a hallucination see
like i said it was kind of like well
amityville horror did that but yeah i
kind of feel like it was it actually it
wasn't blood in amityville or was it it
was like that black goopy [ __ ]
that was coming out of the toilet i
always had this
okay
in the two paranormal
events involving things that were like
ghosts
ghost-like
things that i saw
i never saw an apparition
but i always assumed based on what other
people said
that the apparition was something that
you didn't actually see it was an image
that was placed into your mind by this
thing
in other words
if you were if you were looking at it
and you pulled out a camera to take a
picture of it there wouldn't be anything
there when you looked at the camera
the image was something that placed
directly into your mind kind of like it
was done with telepathy that's how i
always imagined it and i always imagined
that some of these effects like
blood running down walls or something
like that you know you might hear about
into some story
and then it's gone
i my only explanation to myself was they
that image must have been placed into
their minds through telepathy
you know
well i think that's what and that's
basically what this story is saying if
this kind of stuff does exist then yeah
maybe it can like make you see things
which would explain why other people
don't see the same [ __ ] as you and why
you can't ever photograph it poltergeist
it didn't make me see anything it moved
things we saw that saw some blue haze
but there wasn't any apparitions or any
what do you call them hallucinations or
anything
then later on at the bat house never saw
anything never saw anything move never
saw any apparitions never heard anything
just an intense feeling of presence
and never could prove it
there's just a bad house
and other people were the same way like
man this is not good whatever this is i
was like i know i don't know what it is
something in here
and he'd have to walk his girlfriend to
the bathroom and guard him while they
were taking a pee in there and then
they'd come out they wouldn't want to
walk down the hallways by themselves
it was a bad house
but i never could prove anything nobody
could nothing ever moved i never saw
anything
nothing ever happened
just feelings
i felt like i got attacked by feelings a
wave of fear and anger
and hatred and i threatened to [ __ ]
burn the house down and it vanished and
it would like
and it would come and go
over time but it never moved anything
you know
so was it my imagination was it our
imagination
who knows
how are you gonna prove it or disprove
it it was just feelings you know
oh somebody sent a super yeah i know i
was waiting for you to stop talking so i
could say thank you
i'm doing a show i know i'm just saying
uh yeah thank you very much trey loving
these guys thank you very much blockpark
says i'm late again we're still we're
still only like halfway through the
episode don't worry about it yeah you
got time we've been like farting around
for ages yeah i'm joking around [ __ ]
joking around i'm sitting here looking
at jenny's sexy legs her legs are
getting so nice she's been [ __ ]
riding on that damn bicycle and [ __ ]
you're getting shapely
uh-huh i'm gonna hit that focus okay i'm
focused
trey said sorry to interrupt like that
no i'm glad you did because okay i
wanted to get back to like what i was
talking about okay all right so so yeah
so like the blood is running down the
wall right yeah
so
she even touches it the actress that
they had in this she um
she acted with her mouth a lot let's say
that she always had like her mouth open
like really big like injury
you know no no yeah but she's good i
like her yeah she was actually really
good at it
i liked her a lot yeah she's been in
some other episodes it wasn't just this
one but yeah so she sees the blood
dripping now there's like a lot of it
too it's like it started out as like one
or two drips but then it was just like a
whole story all over the wall it's like
from amdville yeah like auntie lahore so
she goes over there and like touches it
and then there's blood on her finger
right and she's like wigging out but the
daughter becky comes running out
and she's like look at the wall and like
becky looks at the wall she's like mom
are you tripping there's like nothing
there so then it's like disappeared and
she's like i got it on my hand and then
she looks at her hand and then there's
nothing there now
i wasn't sure because i'm like watching
the episode i watched it a couple times
like before we did this we watched it
last night and i watched it again this
morning like and i went through it a
couple times like while i was taking
notes on it
and
she never said that she actually saw
blood running down the walls but she did
say in the interview like the real sarah
said
i thought that was our blood so i'm
assuming she did see some kind of i
don't know if it was as dramatic as like
all of this kind of like blood running
down the wall
but she did say she didn't make
reference to
seeing blood i guess i placed a vision
in her head yeah like a premonition
that's that's that's what that's my
interpretation of what we're being shown
it was there and then it went away
they're not saying it was physically
there and then it vanished
that's not that that that would be very
inefficient
for a spirit or a paranormal force to do
be more efficient to just put that
directly into your mind
you know
an illusion danny rowling said must have
been that house's time of the month
right yeah it was it was the house's
period yeah
um he also said the mom and the daughter
actors actually looked alike in this
episode yeah they did they did actually
well the only thing that's funny about
the mom and the daughters it looked like
there's five years between them
yeah they didn't yeah the mom didn't
really look that much older than the
daughter the daughter looked like she's
about 17 and she's supposed to be 13 but
she's clearly older though yeah she
looked like about 17 or 18 the mom
looked like she's about 25. yeah didn't
really look possible oh well yeah what
are you gonna do yeah zach says what's
the worst acting you've seen in a
haunting episode
oh [ __ ]
well the thing is is that i don't want
it most of the acting isn't that bad
like it doesn't stick out stand out it
doesn't stick out
because
everybody on it is is at least
serviceable they're delivered they
deliver you know they're doing pretty
good yeah nobody stood out as being bad
and honestly like i've seen actual
movies
that had worse actually
than anybody on this channel so
even season eight which is the worst
season i've seen so far in this series
had good acting
yeah the production value was okay
the quality of the stories are kind of
declined a little bit but that's not the
actors it's not the active part it's not
the company's fault it's just that
they're [ __ ] scraping the bottom of
the barrel for interesting [ __ ]
stories about awnings
there's not many cases out there these
things are rare
and uh or at least people reporting them
is rare
you know
when we had ours there's no way to
report them
and you know there's no way to report
the bad house but i'm gonna tell
somebody
yeah we were in this house had bad
feelings in there we never saw anything
nothing removed but that's just a bad
house oh well thanks [ __ ] out of here
okay
you know yeah [ __ ] like that is probably
pretty common it's just that nobody
reports them there's no proof
you don't have proof to yourself i don't
can't prove it to myself i just know
what i felt i know what i saw everybody
else feeling
something was bad in that house
but the
mammoth was worse so you can see it
moved but that was more exciting you
could see [ __ ] move
something was in there
yeah and then it happened at lois's
house and that's great you know if you
guys don't know the case read the book
jenny wrote it good
lois was involved and read he
before he died he told reminded me of a
bunch of stuff that happened at that
house
well it was in two houses but uh and it
only lasted for two weeks and then it
went away
and it happens here every now and then
but you know
but yeah so i'm guessing that real sarah
did see something approximating what
they showed on the show because she did
say you know something about blood so i
guess but she didn't say exactly like
that it looked on the show but she
finally believes becky she's like oh my
god there is something in here and
becky's like duh that's what i've been
trying to tell you like the whole time
so then they go sit in sarah's room and
like pray and whatnot now the next day
jack actually moves into becky's room
because they don't want anybody staying
in that room anymore
so sarah goes and hangs a picture of
jesus in the closet of the curse room
since that seems to be where the
activity is stemming from poor old jesus
and he's in there in the closet going
don't leave me here it's dark you know i
don't know but yeah they say they just
like pin a picture of him in the closet
because they think that's gonna help
so then uh sarah's boyfriend steve comes
to visit and he's uh he's a real dick in
this episode he's he's kind of like one
of the quintessential like male
characters you're ridiculous blah blah
blah he's real dismissive about this
whole haunting situation and it's kind
of funny because he comes to visit
and then they're kind of sitting in
front of the fire and he's like hey
honey what's wrong and she's like i
don't know this is like a bad house and
i want to move and he's like i don't
believe in any of that stuff blah blah
blah hey marry me you know what i mean
it's like it's almost that abrupt and
she's like oh okay yay and like yeah so
i was like
smooth that was a real smooth marriage
proposal there um he's like yeah i'm
gonna dismiss your feelings but hey
here's a ring um so that'll make you
feel better so he's gonna move into the
house with them like after the wedding i
don't know like i thought that was like
really weird i'm like well can you not
like move in now or do are you one of
those people that's like they can't live
together until they're married or i
don't know it just seemed kind of weird
i don't know i'm not judging i'm just
saying i thought it was odd
so
one day becky is i don't know putting
laundry away or some [ __ ] like that
everybody's always doing laundry on the
show like the women are always doing
laundry i noticed because i guess that's
something that
you know people have to do all the time
so when you're in the house it's
something that people can carry around
so it looks like you're not just
wandering around the house with no
purpose
so she has like all these sheets or
whatever and she's kind of curious about
what's going on in the old room you know
with the jesus picture and whatnot uh
and i guess it's been closed off since
the last incident
so she goes in and opens the closet door
and she finds that old jesus
the picture has been turned upside down
uh so
now i will say i don't know what it was
like in real life it would be
considerably weirder if for example uh
you had a picture of jesus that was like
framed and like you had the whole thing
like mounted on the wall like with a
screw and like all of that kind of stuff
but on the episode they basically just
showed it was like an 8 by 10 glossy it
wasn't framed or anything
in like pinned to the wall like
essentially with a push pin you know
what i mean like a thumbtack
so
i don't know like so i i wasn't all that
impressed that like you know you'd open
the closet door and it's like oh it's
upside down because i'm like yeah but
somebody could have reached into the
closet and like gone like that and the
picture would just kind of get stuck up
like they're i don't know but so i don't
know i just wasn't all that impressed
but whatever but so jesus is upside down
being like help me and so then he was i
don't know and so then uh she screams
for her mom
and uh mom comes in there and sees the
jesus and then she's like you know she
fixes it very slowly thank you
and uh she's like okay um nobody is
allowed in here anymore anything that
can turn a picture of jesus upside down
on a single thumbtack is nothing to be
trifled with clearly
so
i'm just i'm being as smart as i know
um so sarah starts wondering what is the
deal like with the evil presence in this
house maybe somebody was murdered in
here that was one idea that she had so
she's like i'm gonna go talk to the
neighbor lady
so she goes next door a neighbor ladies
putting her hedges or whatever and she
basically the neighbor lady basically
says yeah i was wondering when you were
going to come over here and ask about
that and
uh and apologizes for not kind of
contacting her sooner
now the neighbor says now as far as i
know
nobody died in the house
but the woman who used to live there
before
had a teenage daughter
who maybe practiced black magic
always blame the goths that's what they
do on this show man yeah she had [ __ ]
dyed hair was i feel attacked black and
she had
black clothes and she had [ __ ] black
fish nets on she and the fishnets were
on her arms she's worshiping the devil
she lived in that house so it's haunted
thank you camp guy thank you cam guy
cool tuesday to everybody yeah thank you
for another ten dollars thank you thank
you we didn't get any super chats last
night yesterday we didn't we gotta think
about two dollars yeah five dollars i
think yeah we have we got it we got a
couple
trying to pay these bills up in this
[ __ ]
but we understand it man [ __ ] economy
is bad right now nobody's got any money
nobody's got anybody
we get through it though
and and think about it
if you all lose money and we lose money
that means nobody's got money and when
nobody's got money then bills can't be
paid the whole [ __ ] system breaks
down and if nobody can pay any bills
then [ __ ]
i've been there before
brazil was like that during the collapse
argentina and [ __ ]
just how it is
you americans will learn
so what are you europeans you learn
okay go ahead zach says uh knowing this
show if they made an episode about tom's
story they'd probably get like a fat
blonde kid to play tom
wouldn't be accurate
at the time i did at the time
uh mammoth mountain was going on i was
like uh 14 or 15. i was cute as [ __ ] i
look like a girl i look like [ __ ]
demi moore
i thought you were 13. 13. yeah it
looked like do me more same kind same
haircut everything
that would be hilarious if they actually
found like a little 13 year old actor
that looked like a male to me more yeah
i remember around that time [ __ ]
every now and then teenage guys would
mistake me for a girl sometimes weird
but way it was
not that i went to school with you know
tom was pretty yeah it was pretty for a
while
yeah but yeah so this was another show
where they always blame somebody's goth
teenage daughter for having black masses
in the house and like opening up a
doorway to hell and [ __ ] like that we
always get the [ __ ] blade for this
kind of stuff man i feel attacked i'm
just saying no i'm just kidding i don't
feel attacked but uh yeah so i even
wrote my notes as always we blame the
gods
so um
at this point uh so sarah decides she's
gonna call the priest like she has a
priest because i guess their church
going folks so she calls her parish
priest to come in for a blessing
so the priest comes in and blesses the
house she said that seemed to work for
about a month yeah it always works for a
little while but you know if you've seen
this show you know it doesn't last she
said actually all that time like the
house felt normal like felt safe and
comfortable all that time and during
this time period i'm assuming at least
like what they said on the show timeline
uh sarah and steve get married and steve
moves in
then one friday night steve goes out of
town to visit his dad like on the ranch
or whatever because it's always when the
man is out he never experiences stuff
not always because but 99 of the time on
these shows it's always like when the
dude is at work or he's out of town or
something like that so steve has gone
out of town to visit his dad
sarah gets woken up in the middle of the
night by the feeling of something
choking her
okay like she wakes up and she's just
like feels like something's like around
her uh hands around her neck she then
says she says something in latin
and she finds out later that this
translates to
we are here now i was curious about this
uh what she said on the show i'm not
sure i didn't take latin in high school
i took french no summer c
but
i looked up on google translate i was
like what is the latin translation from
we are here and they said it was
hiksumus yeah but she was saying no sumo
c
i couldn't tell what she was saying
because i'm definitely almost because we
or we are
but it doesn't mean
somos means
the permanent state of being which means
we are
estar
is
is the location based r
so there's a big difference between set
and the star so see i figured it was
some yeah
that's what i figured and i don't know
what c is
yeah she kept saying that i'm like where
is where are you getting that from we
are a we are a something or other we are
a you know if it was a location it would
be nos
okay
aqui
we are here
yeah nostalgia
but we are here
that's what that's portuguese basic
latin it's probably the same in spanish
and it's going to be real similar in
french here is easy i see i yeah and
italian's going to be similar yeah
strangely enough romanian is going to be
similar well that's not that strange
that it's similar but it's not supposed
to be a latin language but i can
understand romanian
it's real similar to [ __ ]
portuguese and a brazilian says isn't it
funny man you can understand romanians
yeah but it's not classified as a latin
language but we can understand it if
you're if you speak brazilian portuguese
carioca or paulistano then you you can
understand it
and it's not supposed to be the same
because it's supposed to be cyrillic
but it's all roman empire stuff it's all
descended from wrong that's what i mean
if you look back to the history right
yeah it should be that surprisingly
honestly even though they use a
different house whatever they had that
actress saying it's wrong
see that's what i suspected that's why i
looked it up because i'm like that
doesn't sound quite right like i said i
didn't take latin but i have taken i
took french for four years i've taken
spanish and i took a little bit of
italian also and i'm like that doesn't
sound exactly right it was like too many
syllables i don't know it just it didn't
sound right
and that's the permanent state of being
we are the of a permanent state
it does not translate into english or
any kind of germanic language
so she's not saying
she's not giving a location she's giving
a nature we are a human we are a bear we
are a
white person we are a something you know
what i mean
if it's a location it's going to be no
sustamos
because it's a it's it's a temporary
state of being
you know what i'm talking about yeah
so she's saying a permanent state of
being it's init it's she's saying what
her nature is not where her location is
right it's wrong
whatever it is
that's what i figured yeah i said that's
why i looked it up because i was like
curious right she said no someone will
see no sum will see and i'm like you're
a you're a c i am a c
i don't know what a c is
yeah yeah like i said i'm not sure how
accurate google translate is but they
they basically yeah yeah they they said
uh hicksomus
yeah yeah s-u-m-u-s somos we are yeah we
are it's a conjugated verb yeah it's
almost
which sounds more i mean that sounds
more accurate
because we are here that's a very simple
phrase like hey we're in your house
[ __ ] all the latin languages are
running the same verb and the verb right
conjugation system you don't really
that's why they call them they're very
easy to translate most of what's
happening
you may not know the right fine details
but you can understand
who is what and what is kind of
happening yeah they're all structured
they're all structured about the same
because like i said i took french for
four years and then when i started
learning italian
it was structured it was very similar so
and a lot of the words were you know
similar so you would kind of like you'd
be able to figure it out
so sarah finds out what this phrase
means that she's been saying and you
know freaks out because obviously you
have some
ghosts in your house saying hey here we
are like but i don't know that i feel
like they already knew that it's like
yeah duh you're already here why didn't
you say that um but yeah so she's like
freaked out
so steve comes home because he's been
visiting his dad and he's been gone all
weekend so he comes home on sunday
evening
and she tries to tell him what's going
on but he like again he's a real douche
on this show and he just like totally
blows her off and she's like you know
what [ __ ] [ __ ] off like never mind um
i'll just like deal with it my own self
because i know you don't believe me and
you suck
um
and she said basically steve never heard
anything or saw anything in the house uh
and that he never understood like she
tried to tell him about the stuff and
she just felt like really isolated alone
their relationship started getting kind
of strained because she was
kind of always dealing with it and he
was just kind of like i just think
you're being ridiculous yadda yadda
so uh so then the next thing that
happens becky is in her room one night
and this isn't even the cursed room this
is the grandma room that she moved to
and she's sitting in her bed and she
said she felt like something
breathing on her she's like close by she
said it felt like the really cold breath
like someone with really cold breath was
like breathing in her ear
and so she jumps up off the bed and then
she goes and like
looks in other parts of the room and
then it does it again like while she's
standing up
and then she turns around and sees
a big creepy
head like a disembodied head on the show
it looked like
much larger than a regular head but i
don't know if that's what she saw or not
she did say
um the quote and i wrote it down she
said a head in air
no body
it looked like she was dead that's what
she said now on the show they just
showed this big but it was a big [ __ ]
head you know what i mean like a not
just like a head size head it was like
two or three times the regular size and
i thought it was a dude because i said
oh it looked like a rob zombie character
but
she said it was she so i guess it was a
woman and actually like if you see the
um
stills of like the actress that played
that
demon it's very clearly a woman but in
the show like you couldn't really tell
it just looked like a scary head
so there's that so becky runs into the
living room where uh sarah and steve are
still kind of fighting about the [ __ ]
and she's just like it breathed on me
and she's like wigging out about that
and uh steve is just like jesus christ
oh my god this is like so ridiculous and
he's just like walking out
she's like we have to move there's like
i saw a [ __ ] head or like a big face
or something like that steve's not
having it and she's like we really need
to move um you know and like i said
steve is like you're being ridiculous
we're not going anywhere
now at this point um sarah is like
worried about
becky the teenager so she actually
allows becky to move back to reading
where they move from like she moves in
with like her friend's family or
something um because she can't stay in
the house anymore
so um the interview like real becky said
she said i felt really bad because i got
to leave the house and sarah and jack
like were still stuck there um but you
know i was relieved to to get out of
there
sarah is kind of having a hard time uh
emotionally and financially she's like i
really did want to move but i couldn't
afford to and i was stuck and then like
steve wasn't believing me and he was
being a real douche about it she didn't
say that but it's like you know the
actor was being a douche anyway
and then she said that after her
daughter left she said that the demon or
whatever the [ __ ] it was uh started
mimicking her daughter's voice like just
to [ __ ] with her like she'd be like they
showed her like doing some laundry or
something like that and then she'd hear
her daughter's horse going mom and then
she'd turn around and be like what the
[ __ ] like it's the demon doing that so i
guess it was like trying to just like
[ __ ] with her so she yells at the demon
like yeah you [ __ ] did it you tore
the family up so just like [ __ ] off
so at this point like sarah contacts a
real life person john considine
at phantasm psychic research in
connecticut which he founded with his
wife in 1994. so constantine he's like a
demonology guy uh and he works with
bishop robert mckenna again and i think
i mentioned this earlier who's quite
famous he worked on like kind of a lot
of big cases but he's probably most
famous for being involved in the smurl
haunting uh which was kind of a big
thing and that was actually remember we
did that did that 1991 tv movie the
haunted that was about the smurl
haunting i don't think they made like a
big hollywood movie about it
but i wrote about it in my book
and i you know and i know that they made
that tv movie which was actually not bad
if you haven't seen it
so john constantine goes to talk to
bishop mckenna before he flies out to
california and then he does he's like
okay well if i'm going to go and deal
with this i have to do like the whole i
nine day fast and praying and purging
and all that kind of it's not purging
like throwing up but like you know what
i mean purging of your sins or whatever
yeah
because as soon as i said purging i'm
like so you're like being like bulimic
or
i don't know it's common and it goes
through yes and western religions i know
i'm just the dallas priests do it and
everything to try to [ __ ] purge out
all their impurities it goes all the way
back to them
persia also with the zoroastrianist
zoroastrian concept of hell you're bad
you go to hell to burn off impurities so
you can become clean again and then you
come back out for reincarnation you know
it's
it's all that same concept maybe
something to it i know i'm a terrible
vulgar person but when he said that i
was like did he also like not jerk off
for nine days
probably that probably yeah a bunch of
ritual purity that's what i was thinking
so i was like he's not not going to say
that on the show but i'm like i'm i
thought that was
scientific okay biological [ __ ] behind
that [ __ ] uh no fap no fap [ __ ] uh
no fab no
no fap would actually for male increase
uh
testosterone production probably in
libido and energy okay i gotta run so
you can have the strength you need to
fight these goddamn damage
because you want to fight a [ __ ]
demon with a full-on hard-on that you're
just ready at any minute that's right
you could just pop up pop
pop a rock on them damn [ __ ] demons
and [ __ ] get down to business
um so
uh yeah long tradition maybe some
science behind it your testosterone
might be a little bit higher during that
which get puts more fight in you
now i've always heard i don't know i was
never a professional boxer
but i know back in the 70s and the 80s
um evidently
pro boxers would have no sex no fap
rules and [ __ ] for like
two or three weeks before a [ __ ] big
professional fight
the trainers of that era thought that a
dude [ __ ] would fight harder and and
fight longer and have better endurance
if he was
let's just say unsatisfied
and there may be something to that if
you understand how the endocrine system
works his a male's testosterone levels
might be higher
okay
and testosterone of course is it as a
performance drug and if you can't bump
these dudes up with [ __ ] steroids
and
testosterone before the fights
you might get a slight advantage if
there was a no fight rule no fap rule
and no sex rule couple weeks before the
[ __ ] pro fight and there's a lot of
money riding on it
so they're gonna be grasping for every
[ __ ] straw they can any advantage
they can so maybe something to it and
that might have been
known even in the ancient times maybe
guys noticed that if there was no fat no
sex we even on the priest level
that you might have higher endurance
which would mean higher testosterone
uh higher free testosterone in your
bloodstream so something to it probably
so you're going to like try and beat the
demon into submission with your uh
erection
no it's uh
i was that would be like without being
away from making a joke but you know
[ __ ] higher free testosterone levels
always always equate to [ __ ]
better physical and mental endurance
it does and if you uh this is before
this is before the ability to synthesize
[ __ ] testosterone now that we're here
in the modern world
you can inject all the testosterone you
want
okay it works [ __ ] right it does
but uh no the ancients probably knew
something about they evidently noticed
evidently they did
they didn't give any sex
to any pro
gladiators in the roman era until after
they won victories
so they knew they were done
so yeah nine days no food uh all the
praying purging we're assuming no
fapping yeah i'm just like that's
implied yeah so how are enough you're
powering up sure to fight the demons
yeah with your erection or whatever
better mental acuity everything
everything like it well it's it's
funnier it's funny it's funnier you
think of like somebody beating a demon
outside your head with their arrest i'm
just trying to go away i'm just trying
to justify what it is they're thinking
so yeah well i get it i get it it's just
funny to think about right so all right
so the phantasm team go out to
california
what are you paid for their flight
interesting uh so they went in june of
2001. now he says when he got there uh
he said there was a quote unquote sense
of doom and feeling of being watched in
the house that's what he said he brings
uh three other people on his team like
there's one guy who's like an older guy
who's like the tech guy and then uh his
wife who's also like the co-founder her
name is barbara i think or something and
then uh barbie hyde who is the quote
unquote light clairvoyant not like one
of those heavy clairvoyants but she's
she's doing some light clairvoyant i
don't really know what the difference is
between a light clairvoyant i don't know
why that stuck out to me that they
called i'd never heard that phrase
before
and i was just kind of like well how is
a light clairvoyant different than a
regular clairvoyant regular clarifying
immediate we have the light heavy
clarence is someone who's really pulling
out the ass the real true performer okay
or they're really fat they're fake okay
i don't know
a light clairvoyant i think any
clairvoyant would be a light clairvoyant
if there's a clairvoyant okay so it's
clairvoyant it's sometimes right just a
casual clairvoyance yeah i can kind of
maybe that's it you're talking about a
force sensitive that's what they're
talking about okay
now she was at like the real person of
this was actually like on the show her
and john content the other two people on
the team were not but these two were
actually uh really on their new
listeners of the show i'll use some damn
star wars terminology okay which is some
truth to what they're talking about they
didn't write pull that out of their ass
that's all taoist and buddhist [ __ ]
[ __ ] some other stuff so what they're
talking about is they're talking about
somebody who's force sensitive that's
what they're talking about
yeah she's a light clairvoyant oh yeah
just i'm doing something she's not a
jedi she's force sensitive doesn't like
right uh so yeah so she was on the show
too so they're planning to live with the
family for a week so uh during this week
becky has actually come back uh from
reading like from her friend's house and
she's gonna stay there for the
investigation but the little kid who's
only five they send him off to stay with
grandma so nothing bad happens
so the first night now they all camp out
in the living room
with one of the team kind of staying
awake to monitor the equipment and then
the other ones sort of like sleeping in
ships essentially
now john considine says um that he was
sleeping on the floor like in his little
sleeping bag
and then he was very suddenly and
actually this was a pretty creepy effect
uh on the show because he's laying there
flat and then he was like supernaturally
like pulled to his feet from a flat
position on the floor so like
i'm trying to explain like what it
looked like it was like what like that
like without bending no bending knees of
anything he just kind of went
planking up like that like nosferatu did
yeah like a plank kind of said yeah like
nasparachi there yeah
um now just prior to this happening
because i guess barbie the like
clairvoyant i guess she's i'm just gonna
call her the likelier win it sounds like
a radio station
welcome to the light clear point but
yeah so yeah she said prior to that
happening she said it sounded like a
bomb went off and john considine also
said that he heard like they heard a
really loud noise like a bomb going off
and then he goes whoop and then like he
gets like right to his feet and he was
like wigged out and like he woke up
so uh
considine's theory was that um this is
the demonic what's this
trying to scare them off so they won't
help the family so he's like look i can
just like pull you up just like right
like that so how do you like that erica
said becky with the good hair i don't
know who uh oh becky with the guy what's
she talking about um yeah i can't i know
that that's a reference to something but
i can't like remember what it is at the
moment but yeah that's a reference to
something right probably that you
haven't seen yeah probably out of here i
don't know what she's referring to
tom has a lot of like cultural blind
spots
where there's like a lot of
there's a lot of cultural references
like to movies and songs and stuff like
that that like i feel like everybody
knows but he's not me he doesn't know
that [ __ ] i love [ __ ] going on the
internet and [ __ ] seeing that people
commenting on the news comment on a
daily mail and when they pull it up they
see on the right side of the page
they'll have all the damn
celebrity news and i don't know a single
one of those [ __ ] celebrities well
it's not necessarily celebrities i don't
know a lot of them i don't know a single
[ __ ] celebrity and [ __ ] i can go
back in time and i don't know a single
[ __ ] celebrity from [ __ ] 20 years
ago i'm so proud of myself i don't
[ __ ] know those i know their names i
don't know anything they do like i know
justin bieber is [ __ ] famous i
couldn't pick that dude up out of a
[ __ ] lineup i don't know that was a
long time ago yes i'm saying i don't
even know even a long time ago i don't
know i couldn't pick him i kind of know
what he looked like when he was a kid
but i don't know what he looks like i
couldn't pick him up out of a lineup i
don't know anything he did i've never
even heard of in his songs i i'm so
proud
that i'm so detached i mean is that
really something to be proud of though
because yeah i don't want i don't even
give a [ __ ] no just it proves my purity
that i give a [ __ ] well if you were
really pure you wouldn't even like bring
it up
no i'll just see that
i'm proud of you thomas
and he got like these [ __ ] chicks
[ __ ] twerking all the time and
they're supposed to be famous i don't
know who the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is you know
i don't give a [ __ ] about that dude that
chicks ass i just don't care
you know what i mean
but they got
young people giving millions of dollars
to these [ __ ] big booty girls i don't
give a [ __ ] but the thing about it is
that i don't like i don't care either
but the thing about it is that i don't
want to be one of those people that
because i remember when i was growing up
in the 80s and like all the old people
were just kind of like
who the [ __ ] are those people like what
are you young people doing it's like and
i kind of don't want to be that old
person that sounds like that there's a
big difference though back in those days
you only had four television stations
and a few radio stations so yeah you
should have nowadays you can't really
keep that
so much so many of them they're all
disempowered
because [ __ ] um nobody had no it's
all [ __ ] divided up
so the old system's dying because
they're they're not they can't force you
to watch
but the thing about it like i said and i
think that i like that better because
even though
you know obviously you don't have the
same references i think that's probably
why a lot of cultural references that
everybody understands are usually from
older from like from 80s or 90s because
that was a time when most everybody saw
the same thing you didn't have so if
somebody like refers to that's why a lot
of memes and stuff like that are
referring back to like 80s movies 90s
movies stuff like that because you know
everybody kind of saw those and they've
had like
like nowadays
you know people make memes about stuff
that but it's it's very kind of
compartmentalized because you you know
everybody's fan fandom
is
sort of but like i said that's okay
because you can kind of find whatever
the [ __ ] you want and other people don't
know [ __ ] about it and that's all right
i only care about youtube that's all
right i only care about youtubers
you know
and i got friends who are [ __ ]
hollywood stars i got my ex-girlfriend's
hollywood star i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't it's just funny
and mary lynn [ __ ] messages me we'll
[ __ ] message each other and joke
around [ __ ] she doesn't give a [ __ ]
either she's just making money
she's just interested well that's what i
mean it's like it's just it's just a job
she's just in another compartment it's
just a job yeah she she's seen this show
and she goes oh you guys are great you
know it's it's just another j it's just
a she's in another compartment that's
that's the only there it's the rules a
little bit different over there but
these compartments open and close it's
just another gig
it right
so i'm really not that worried about it
it's just like i'm not going to be all
grandma and it's like oh i don't know
these kids
well because the thing about it is like
well what kids today are you talking
about because everybody has their own
there's all niche you know it's all
niche yeah and like i said that's fine
like you know there's youtubers there's
tick tock people there's all these that
have like millions of followers and i
don't know jack [ __ ] about that but then
there's kind of like other youtubers or
tic tac people that have millions of
followers and i do know about that
because it's something i'm interested in
like somebody that's looking for
halloween decor or some [ __ ] like that
but that's okay though like you know not
everybody has to like the same thing as
me and i don't have to like the same
thing as everybody else like you can
just like watch whatever the [ __ ] you
want i'm not gonna like worry about it
and i'm not gonna like go around saying
it's like oh i'm so glad i don't know
anything but there's too much nowadays
you know and i think that's good i mean
it's harder to get noticed obviously but
it's good because you can find exactly
what you like
and you know yeah and you can kind of
find your own people your own little
[ __ ] that you're interested in there's
nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with that at all
so um yeah verica it's double 07. of
course it's double he's double seven
[Laughter]
of course it's double seven he's been
around the world yeah yeah um well he
was in the military and he also i mean
before you were in the middle of nowhere
he's involved in government he lived in
uh brazil for a long time because of his
uh parents you know well my mother yeah
your mom but she was a single
uh mom at that time she was in the state
department
she was secretary of the consul general
she did about she worked for other
agencies dea was one of them she worked
for it was all [ __ ] okay
um
you know uh that whole side of the
family was government government
government contractors same with me
you know that's all i'm gonna say about
it right now good
danny rowling said i liked when
celebrity celebs had terrible stained
teeth on camera unlike today were they
all veneers or super white fake color
teeth honestly i kind of liked and like
i said i don't want to be the old person
that's like you know it's like oh
everything was better back in the day
but i did kind of like that back then
everybody just kind of looked like a
normal person now everyone kind of looks
like a sex bot
you kind of have to because that's what
i mean hdtv now that's what i mean so
everybody has to be like completely
the thing was is that in the olden days
they needed a lot more charm and
charisma i mean it didn't matter what
you look like
you had to have a personality behind you
and you had great people back in the 60s
70s even the 80s you know what i mean
they had some real class acts that will
never be replaced
you know sammy davis jr
[ __ ]
tom de louise what the [ __ ] man you know
they just had good
people yeah you had to be a character
you had to be a character
[ __ ] gene wilder
pryor
these [ __ ] were just legends
eddie murphy early eddie murphy all
funny guys but yeah
you had yeah this goes to show [ __ ]
chris reeves christopher reeves you just
had some class acts back then
i don't know if they'd sell today
because nothing really sells it's just
you have to have heart no i mean it does
but just not to
the comm you know the culture at large
it's just that like you know little
pieces of the yeah they would all be
smaller today they would still be famous
but they'd be smaller right that's what
i mean they'd be famous like in their
own little
niche world right and you said just
everybody youtube is the television of
this era
this is the way tv was tv was
disrespected back when we were kids
movies were respected tv was
disrespected
this is now tv
that's why we're disrespected
real actors this weren't on tv yeah but
that's that com that distinction has
completely gone by the wayside yeah well
and especially yeah in the past
i think that even started in the 1990s
but as time went on and especially as
streaming came on and like you know uh
streaming services like did their own tv
series like a lot of that [ __ ] was like
really good and then people were like
holy crap like this is
artistically just as good as like movies
youtube is great because it's kind of
like
access television reality television and
tv all and radio all mixing into one
thing
and you can choose whatever you want
there's a huge selection well it's just
low but it's personalized it's for you
well that's what i mean and it's like so
you can find exactly what you want and i
think that what a lot of people like
particularly on youtube and like i said
i know that there's you know tick tock
and all that kind of stuff but
particularly on youtube i kind of feel
like what a lot of people like what gets
a lot of views at least from uh you know
the massive uh subscriptions that i have
is
people that are just like real ass
people like doing regular [ __ ] it's just
like hey i'm driving around looking for
halloween decorations at different
stores in my city or hey i'm uh going to
aldi and buying five dollars worth of
ingredients and making dinner for my
family out of it it's like that kind of
just regular kind of [ __ ] and it's just
it's not super high
you know quality or super like edited or
high budget
or anything like that it's just like a
normal ass person right it's that yeah
that's what makes it more accessible
right and what's another thing that's
great is that if you guys are young you
don't know what it was like back in the
[ __ ] days the porn's better
used to be back in the day porn was
artificial as [ __ ] he needed [ __ ]
tens of thousand dollars worth of
equipment you need a whole crew of
[ __ ] people to make goddamn porn and
it [ __ ] was stale as [ __ ] it [ __ ]
it sucked
nowadays just some girl with her phone
and her boyfriend can make porn
and it's more real
that's what i'm saying i like i would
not go back
because yeah some things were better
because like i said you know if you're
new here like i was born in 1972 and you
were born in 1969 so we're so we mostly
grew up in the 70s and 80s yeah there
was a lot of [ __ ] that was better back
then i'm not saying that but
i wouldn't want to go back though like i
think a lot of stuff nowadays is better
some things that were produced will
never be replaced they're [ __ ]
masterpieces
you know what i mean certain things that
were done
certain movies
certain television programs but in
general most of that was [ __ ]
and most of the clothes sucked
the food was good but not all the food
a lot of the food was kind of you had
some stodgy ass [ __ ] yeah creamy
[ __ ] thick [ __ ]
[ __ ]
denny's [ __ ] [ __ ] food go to
denny's today it's a lot better than it
was i worked at a denny's it's better
now
yeah they had some bad ass pizza back in
the 70s their [ __ ] pizza was [ __ ]
great if you knew where to go
but i guess that's with anything
you know
let's get back to the show okay well i
mean we're almost done we're almost done
it's just kind of like you know we've
been going on forever after we get down
then
i got food down there waiting yeah i'm
starving all right so
so we did like the plank thing where he
stood up yeah okay so we did that
so uh so basically his theory about why
the demon
like uh planked him or kind of made him
stand up like that
like [ __ ] i'm trying to think of like
there's probably a word but i can't
think of what it is i'm just like making
the jokes it erected him it erected him
doing yeah we're getting back to
erections again why does that always
happen i don't know
uh so yeah so he's like well uh it did
that because it was trying to scare us
away but we're gonna stay and help the
family yadda yadda now the next morning
barbie the light clairvoyant
tune into the lake clairvoyant she's
back in the kitchen making some notes
and praying for strength and all that
jazz and then the dishes in the drainer
start rattling there i think there was
some other [ __ ] like on the
kitchen counter like behind the sink
like a little flower base or some [ __ ]
like that i think that's sort of
rattling too
and then the water like shot out of the
sink drain at least that's what it
looked like on the show like this big
column of water like comes out of the
sink drain and then she said that when
she went over there and looked in the
sink that the water started going back
down the drain
counterclockwise now if you're in
australia you're probably like and uh
because that's how the [ __ ] works down
there but yeah in in the northern
hemisphere
uh that doesn't happen
so
we would probably be although to be
honest i don't even know if i would
notice that i was thinking that when i
was re-watching it i was like would i
even notice that it was like going the
other way i noticed it immediately when
i went in brazil
really yeah because you're on this side
of the equator
i mean i know that but it's like so i
always kind of wonder like if i went to
the southern hemisphere like would it be
something that stuck out to me it was
weird i was like hold on because i
wouldn't have thought that i would
notice it but yeah
as a kid i noticed it's going the other
way
because you're so used to it but you
don't realize you're used to it going
clockwise right counterclockwise on the
other side i was like well that's what i
was kind of thinking about it because i
was like would i notice it yeah i don't
think the average person knows that when
you go on the other side of the equator
the water goes down the drain goes the
other way the other way
well that's what i said well even when
we were watching the episode i was like
oh so you thought you were in australia
for a second because your [ __ ] was like
oh cause that's the southern hemisphere
so it does go counterclockwise but up
here it goes count it goes clockwise as
i saw when i moved there was like 14 or
15 and saw that [ __ ] happen i was like
whoa
and i didn't so maybe that's what it was
yeah yeah i didn't know what's wrong
with your water i didn't know that i
didn't know that it only went down one
way yeah
on this side of the hemisphere it's
weird because you go away and you're
like whoa it's really not something that
would occur to you no it didn't occur to
me i didn't know that that was gonna be
honest and i told my mom mom that
[ __ ] toy went the other way because
you were on the other side of the crater
and you were like what does that matter
and i still really can't grasp why that
matters
that's just why was that it's so weird
that's so weird it's this weird to me
it's just to do the rotation i guess
but so that's what the demon did it made
it made the water go the opposite way
like they were on the other side of the
uh on the other side of the world yeah
which okay
i kind of want a little something more
from the demon but okay but she noticed
it right away apparently she said it
kept go it was going counterclockwise
so later in the week like i said the
team have been staying there for the
whole week so the team have a bunch of
like high-tech doodads you know and they
let becky
use the low frequency microphone which
they call like the big ear you know
you've seen it it's like a big huge
[ __ ] thing like that and it picks up
sounds like blue 300 hertz that's what
you're uh doing
so she puts the headphones on she's like
ooh let me use it and she like walks
around the house with the headphones on
with the big microphone and she gets
wigged out
by hearing some [ __ ] on there now on the
show it sounded like a bunch of voices
like one male voice said something like
shut up and then said she's listening or
something like that somebody's joking
and then yeah now what she actually said
that she heard because you know the real
becky was on the show she said it
sounded like quote unquote a struggle
and a female choking i don't like know
if she heard a male voice saying like
she's listening or anything like that
but apparently she got really wigged out
um i don't think they were recording at
this particular time
conveniently uh so obviously they didn't
have that on the show but she said it
was like really horrible like what she
heard on there
so at this point like john considine
calls uh a bishop mckenna and mckenna's
like hey how's california and he's like
yeah not so good it's
diabolical out here um we got some demon
situation this is not good
and the family's gonna be destroyed if
we don't do something
so later that night they have kind of
like they get everybody together for a
little family meeting constantine tells
them but i keep calling by his last name
but his first name is just john and
that's boring and that's constantine is
kind of cool that sounds like a [ __ ]
it sounds like a fantasy series you know
what i mean like that last name
so uh he tells me he's like uh you
[ __ ] got a demon
so we need to do something and then
sarah says yeah but we have the house
blessed so what the [ __ ] and constantine
says yeah and at least he's admitting
this yeah it's always good to have that
done but
sometimes if you have a demon like you
guys do
then it just uh provokes the [ __ ] which
like we've seen that happen on the show
over and over again uh and the real guy
actually this is a quote like poking a
bear with a stick he said
doing a blessing it just pisses the
demon off and then it's going to get
even worse
so of course considine believes that the
the goddamn goths in the house before
yeah opened the doorway and all these
dirty
they're always [ __ ] stuff up and
opening doorways
and whatnot it's just one of the [ __ ]
gothic [ __ ] uh that's it's what we do
it's what we do the abilities we have we
open up these damn doorways
here come the demons that's right it's
diabolical but yes we haven't done that
a long time
[Laughter]
well that was an episode we should
probably do that i said i could we
should do that episode there is a
deficit an episode of a haunting called
the diabolical yeah it's a good one and
then tom
and then tom started doing that like on
the show
yeah
every time he does that like it cracks
me up for a while he was doing that like
all the time in the middle of a night in
the bed
his legs would [ __ ] open up like that
like that crawling here like that tell
them how diabolical that [ __ ] it is
diabolical yeah
okay yeah so
the [ __ ] goths man they opened up the
doorway to the demons so constantine's
going to do a minor rite of exercise
just a minor exorcism not like the major
exorcism he can well he's not um he
explained earlier on the show and i
think i forgot to mention this john
considine he's not actually clergy or
anything like that but i guess he's like
clergy sanctioned i'm not really sure
how all of that hierarchy works but so
he gave a badge yeah i guess
they gave him like a little thing and
mccard yeah here you go ahead look i can
do a minor rite of exorcism i'm not like
qualified to like the major rate of
exorcism like the whole like full deal
like the father terrorists kind of [ __ ]
they've changed the rules evidently
they're [ __ ] allowing more exorcisms
they trade a bunch more exorcists
need to exercise all the damn pedos in
the church is the first thing
yeah i really wish they'd get around to
that yeah when are they gonna what are
they gonna do that but yeah they haven't
done that yet so he's gonna do a minor
rate of exorcism i know i'm making jokes
i like i know that's a thing but yeah
he's doing a minor rate of exorcism i
just i don't know the terminology just
always made me laugh so he's like um and
we have to do it in the daytime and it's
like for some reason
i don't know for some reason that also
made me laugh because he's like cause
he's scared to do it after dark or i'd
would kind of think that like the demon
wouldn't care like what time of day it
was but he's like we have to do it in
the daytime
because i guess i don't know sunshine
that's god's thing and i don't know so
he's like all right we're gonna do it
like first thing in the morning
so they
start doing it like the next morning
and they're going around the whole house
like room by room and they're going
around with the whole sensor thing with
like the incense in it and it's very
funny and we both commented on this
the sensor in this
has a
cgi incense in it
because
i mean i'm not hating because i guess
like maybe if you put real incense and
they're a real smoke or whatever like it
doesn't look as good on camera so maybe
like they added it in post-production so
yeah so you have like the lady like
swinging the sensor thing around like in
all the rooms but then they like cgi'd
like smoke
you know what i mean it's very clearly
like cgi smoke
so all of the stuff that they brought
because apparently the team i mean they
flew all the way out here from
connecticut to california so they're
like we need to bring everything
possible so they brought like all the
stuff with them like all the stuff for
the exorcism like the sensor and all
whatever the hell else they need the the
thingy that flows what is that thing
called where they
throw the holy water
i know it has a name i'm just i'm just
making the gesture the thing that looks
like a thing was like the silver thing
with like the ball then and you like to
[ __ ] throw holy water with it but
yeah so you do that now all of this
stuff like before they left they
actually got all of the stuff
blessed by bishop mckenna so you know
it's like 100 effective because he just
was like yeah bless all this stuff and
then they brought it with him
so they go through the whole house
um
barbie the uh the light clairvoyant
which i'm just gonna keep i'm gonna
start a radio station now i'm gonna call
it the light clairvoyant
um but yeah so i'm making fun of that
one
[Laughter]
i don't even know if that's her official
title that was just what content i
called her and it's like i don't know
why that was so funny to me
what's that thing called where they
flick the holy water the the silver
thing i don't know what that is it kind
of looks like a dildo that's it well it
doesn't look like a dildo but it's like
a little i don't know with like a ball
at the end and they've like fling the
holy land
to me it always looked like a salt
shaker on the end of a [ __ ] stick on
a stick
salt shaker on a stick yeah i guess
salt shaker dildo i don't know what it
is
but uh so you want one
i'll get you one no it's okay i don't
want salt on it i don't i don't think
that would be a good idea
i'm just saying i think that would be
probably pretty tragic
but yeah so so barbara's a light
clairvoyant um she says while they're
going through the whole house like room
to room
she said that she heard growling gagging
and wretching noises
coming from the closet in becky's old
room the one with like the jesus picture
that got turned upside down that's kind
of where all of the stuff is so they go
through room to room and they're
essentially what they were trying to
imply on the show is they kept pushing
the demon
they were like now we're in this room so
we're pushing the demon into that room
they were pushing the demon and so we're
hurting the demon they were essentially
hurting the demon yeah
and they end up hurting the demon into
the garage which is like the last place
in the house that they're gonna bliss
so barbie the light clairvoyant she um
described what she called an oppressive
atmosphere coming down on you like a
vice that was a quote i wrote that too i
had a feeling yeah yeah so uh while
they're in the garage and like i said i
don't know nobody said they saw this so
this might have been just added for a
dramatic effect but they're in the
garage and they're just like
reading the whatever you know the the
exorcism minor rate of exorcism stuff
and like the lights are flashing and
like stuff is like rattling on the walls
it's the garage so it's like tools and
stuff and uh the scary head appears
while they're doing the thing i don't
know if anybody saw that but you know
they're just doing like a dramatic thing
um
so and it apparently i don't know i kind
of feel like this one the the exorcism
was kind of
anti-climactic i guess because they're
like yeah we went through the whole
house and it's like rattle rattle rattle
and then like the lights are flashing
and then it's like and then amen and
then
and then it all stops like very abruptly
all the only thing was lacking to this
story is uh lorraine warren
jumping in and spraying the damn rose
and
the roses the smell of males
[Laughter]
okay you know you know that [ __ ] had
like some poet yeah so anyway
so anyway uh i didn't do it the demon uh
is gone from the house like i love like
anthony call the guy that does the
narration on this if you don't know his
name that's what his name is um the
demon has been driven back to hell yeah
but
pookie she's making an appearance she's
like put me down daddy yeah she'll be
she's like i don't want to be on tv you
may kiss me yeah
but she's like okay i'll put up with it
for a second
look at she's relaxing
you're looking at her what you're
looking at
what's he matter
she's basically
she's spaced out for a second
relax did you just say she kind of
straight
she's like all right put me down good
job put me down
all right so demon got driven back to
hell evidently out of the garage
uh sarah though thinks that the house
has too many bad memories so she's like
[ __ ] this place she sells it and then
her and steve buy another house across
town which they show like they bring in
the parish priest again and he's out on
the lawn like blessing the [ __ ] before
i'm like did you learn nothing
from last time lin now if you have
demons in there now you're just making
him mad yeah but she just like i don't
know whatever uh becky actually ended up
staying in writing with a friend's
family so she wouldn't have to be
uprooted again they said so that was
that whole situation and that was like
the end of it nothing weird happened
nobody reported anything like i said i
don't know where this house is because
they didn't really even say what town it
was in nobody used their real names so
this one was yeah there's no way to
check on this one not right i mean if
you really want if you're really
determined you could probably you could
probably find out but i didn't have that
much time for that determination like
i'm not going to invade the people's
privacy i don't really know i can't
really analyze it i can only take it a
face value and can't track down who it
is you know so just
not and you know
can't see anything outside
the show you know what i'm doing you
know
in terms of witnesses and everything
just sure no no i i can't tell if it's a
poltergeist or haunting or [ __ ]
whatever
it is but it says it is i guess
i mean i don't believe in demons so
not in the way described in in by the
catholic church no
i don't know what would a demon want
with a person that's what i'm saying
you're talking about a damn angelic
beast like i said if demons really
existed why the [ __ ] would they like
fart around with it wouldn't worry about
this little low level [ __ ] like that i
don't i don't see it i don't see it some
kind of weird evil spirit dis
disembodied evil yeah i can understand
that but not necessarily like a demon in
terms of a fallen angel
be too powerful yeah they'd have better
things to do in the bible they were
destroying whole cities
that's what i'm saying so
so it's like you'd think that they would
be doing that right it's like they're
not just going to [ __ ] around in one
teenage girl's closet for christ's sake
why would they do that right it just
seems like they have better use of their
time oracle said jenny there's a great
book series about a vicar who's an
exorcist on the welsh english border
the merely watkins series by phil
rickman you probably like it ooh that
sounds really good actually i'm going to
write that down because
i'd actually never heard of that so i'm
going to write that down
and see what i can see about it
merrily walking
all right so
let's go get something all right so
we're going to get somebody don't go
anywhere yet okay
it's tuesday so that means tomorrow is
the main show all right and the thing
that won i'm sure you all will be very
i'm excited about this
uh we're doing a show about two horror
icons bella lugosi yeah and boris
karloff because we've already we did a
show about christopher lee and uh peter
cushing
and so we felt like somebody suggested
why don't you do lugosi and karloff and
i'm like oh yeah that's a great idea so
i put that in the patreon poll and it
won handily and i'm glad because
interesting guys a lot of good movies uh
there was some dynamic between the two
not good
but we'll see yeah i think they kind of
like over dramatize it for certain
things but and it's good that we're
talking about we're talking about
karloff too because i've been watching
like for my other channel scarcelon i'm
going to be watching boris karloff's
hosted uh thriller series from the 1960s
i've done the first six episodes and i'm
gonna be doing like the next six
episodes i'm gonna put that up like
probably
later on this month maybe the 24th
something like that it's going to go up
but yeah so
that'll be exciting i think that'll be
fun the movies man they made good movies
both of them did they did and they made
a lot of good movies together and they
made they made like a [ __ ]
yeah they're fascinating like these two
guys so yeah so hopefully you guys can
come and join us for that should be a
fun show should be probably like a
pretty long one i'd imagine too
uh so yeah thanks for dropping by today
thanks for your super chats and we will
see you guys again tomorrow at 6 p.m
eastern standard time
good night